disney has come a long way from the
perfect pretty princess who was lifted
from the depths of some sort of despair
by the handsome prince charming
there are still prince charmings and
still pretty princesses
but as the world turns we've realized
that a woman doesn't need a man to save
her
in fact half the time she's doing the
saving of the love of her life her
kingdom
her family or even herself with the
release of the new trailer for raya and
the last dragon
an epic female-led adventure flick it's
the perfect time to explore the origins
of the disney damsel
and how these new princesses are
changing what young girls think of
traditional feminine power
do people assume all your problems got
solved because a big strong man showed
up
yes disney's very first princess was the
dazzling
snow white in 1937 with unparalleled
beauty
fair skin hair dark as night and a voice
that called to countless woodland
animals
she was the perfect model of what disney
thought a princess should be
[Music]
the creation of snow white was just the
first in a line of formulaic disney
damsels
followed soon after by cinderella in
1950 and aurora in 1959
in these stories there was a young girl
in despair who needed to be saved by the
dashing prince charming
the stories would end in a happily ever
after which
usually meant marriage it's like a dream
a wonderful dream in the early days of
the disney princess
there was a certain mole to fit she was
virtuous kind and beautiful
she could also easily be transformed
into the perfect picture of a princess
thanks to let's say a fairy godmother
and others were often jealous of her
beauty
like cinderella's stepsisters or any
number of evil witches
these princesses also had something very
traumatic in common
they were trapped cinderella was a maid
in her own home
snow white and aurora were cursed and
isolated and ariel who joined the disney
universe in 1989
wanted to escape the sea for a life on
land
still despite the hardships the
princesses remain resilient and kind
this has a lot to do with how females
express their gender identity
weakness was endearing dresses were a
requirement makeup and hair were always
important and becoming a wife to a
handsome man
usually with money was a sought-after
[Music]
fantasy
girls often discover little about
themselves compared to their biggest
revelation which is that they're in love
and completely ready to marry the guy
that they're sure
is the one that's not to diminish the
impact of these movies and the magic
they brought us
all but they are very much a product of
their time when marriage was a necessary
accomplishment
but the disney damsel is often
underestimated jasmine was first
introduced in 1992
and she wasn't interested in marrying
someone her father chose for her
then maybe i don't want to be a princess
anymore she was also brave and capable
other early princesses who showed off
this kind of choose your own adventure
attitude are ariel
who chose to leave the sea for land and
mulan introduced in 1998
who chose to go off to war and fight for
her family
these stories were the start of the
disney princess as a rebel
not as a passive girl being transported
through her own story
there are a few ways that disney
princesses have rebelled over the years
but they often fit into two categories
rebelling against tradition and
rebelling against the typical love story
when it comes to tradition we can think
of belle who first graced our screens in
1991.
reading is one of her most rebellious
traits and men like gaston points it out
constantly as if it's a huge personality
flaw
she refused to be the traditional
feminine character and this
also gives the disney princess her own
autonomy belle wasn't just trapped with
the beast
she chose to go with him to save her
father sure it might not
seem like a hard choice to make but it
demonstrates just how brave
a so-called damsel can be jasmine also
portrays this defiance
refusing to go along with exactly what
her father wants
even though it's what's expected of her
in the live action this is
even more apparent as she wants to
become sultan of agrabah herself
you have shown me courage
and strength ariel also rebelled against
her family and her father's royal
expectations when it comes to romance
not all disney princesses are called to
adventure in order to find their own
true love
pocahontas changed the narrative in 1995
when she fell in love with john smith
but
ultimately chose to stay with her tribe
mulan also fell in love but her
motivation to join the war had
absolutely nothing to do with romance
and she accomplished her goal before
letting herself focus on her love story
as these types of stories gained
popularity we started to see another
shift in the way a disney princess is
portrayed
as she becomes rebellious she also
starts to rebel against the idea of
needing a love interest
it's not just about being able to choose
the man she'll marry
but also being able to choose not to
marry at all
even with feminist characters like belle
we saw a focus on the power of romantic
love in a fairy tale
her love could literally change a
monster back into a man
but as girls and young women yearn for a
call to adventure
we start to see these amazing fantasies
that don't center on romantic love
merida from brave is one example or
moana
and even elsa the trailer for raya and
the last dragon
also doesn't tease any type of love
story raya is looking for a dragon
not a prince disney has also focused on
different types of love that aren't
romantic
like moana's love for her people elsa
and anna's sisterly love
and the powerful mother-daughter bond
shown in brave in maleficent
it's the love of a motherly figure that
wakes aurora not some prince charming
even when there is love disney has
started to flip the script a little on
how it's shown
frozen does contain a love story but
anna and christoph's relationship
is an endearing subplot not the entire
purpose of the story
entangled rapunzel saves flynn awakening
him in a scene that reminds us of when
the handsome prince would kiss the
sleeping princess
but the roles are reversed
this change from damsel to heroin
doesn't have to diminish the more
feminine character
and it actually allows us to shatter the
glass ceiling on what a strong woman
should look like
disney demonstrates this best by pairing
together some very different female
characters who have their own
motivations dreams strengths and
weaknesses
that don't trap them in one particular
box the princess and the frog
illustrates these differences with tiana
and charlotte
tiana dreams of owning a restaurant and
charlotte dreams of marrying a prince
but neither of them seems inferior to
the other in frozen
elsa and anna are very different sisters
with anna being a bit more romantic and
tender-hearted
and elsa being more resistant to love
and tradition and focused on her own
personal growth
plus elsa has strong powers and anna
doesn't
both sisters have things in common but
are still very different
but in both of these films being
different doesn't keep these women from
still being best friends
one of the most important messages these
films display to young girls and boys is
that it's okay to look up to a disney
princess
even to see yourself as one because that
femininity isn't automatically bad
it's just not the only way there is to
be these disney heroines
also represent their own independence
going off on journeys on their own
even when all they see ahead of them is
danger this shift from a princess
needing to be protected to her
literally saving everyone has opened up
a whole new world of skills for the
traditional disney damsel
and disney's newest movies are always
focused on showing off the new ways a
disney princess can take on the world
and take care of herself
of course the most obvious way that
disney tries to subvert expectations of
the traditional
fairy tale and show off a character's
independence is with women that can
fight
and usually they can fight really really
well
there's mulan of course and rebellious
merida
there's also moana who takes the lead
over an actual demigod to save her
island
these disney princesses also fight back
in their own way
like how mulan uses her particular
skills as a warrior and doesn't just
rely on physical strength
or how moana realizes that teka is te
fiti
rapunzel is also not afraid to strike
first and ask questions later
even with a very non-traditional weapon
remakes have helped to make this even
more obvious in some cases
and given disney a chance to redevelop
some of their characters
like jane in the live-action tarzan who
refuses to be a damsel
there's more of a focus on fighting in
the live-action mulan
and even a grungier and more feisty snow
white in snow white and the huntsman
ralph breaks the internet was another
opportunity for disney to bring back its
most famous princesses
and the first thing they do is grab
weapons and prepare themselves to fight
these adventure stories are getting even
more popular in the disney universe
think of the mother in onward i am a
mighty warrior
rushing to her son's rescue and of
course the trailer for raya and the last
dragon which promises a true adventure
story starring a strong female character
these characters are no longer being
pushed through their story by destiny
they're taking destiny into their own
hands
as female motivations and personalities
become more diverse
so are their bodies albeit a bit more
slowly
the mother and onward is one example as
is wreck-it ralph's vanellope with her
small size and distinctive voice
all uncharacteristic of a princess
ladies i'm a princess too
moana is another female character with
more realistic proportions
and it looks like raya's character
design is also less dainty than a lot of
other disney heroines
in up we also get to see a more
realistic portrayal of bodies
and the process of aging but body
diversity is still an area where disney
needs a lot more work
we still don't have a plus size princess
for example they also need to work on
inclusivity of sexual orientations
gender identity and including even more
people of color
though disney has been making strides
with more and more culturally diverse
princesses
as the world continues to change it's
only natural that disney will change
with it
it's been a part of shaping how we see
the world and view fantasy and fairy
tales for a hundred years
and it's not about to slow down anytime
soon so while princesses may be
ever changing we shouldn't count out the
cinderellas and snow whites of the world
as being too modest or meek
being strong confident and rebellious
are things we all work on
we shouldn't put other women down for
fitting a certain mold
especially when these women are fantasy
characters that had to exist within
certain social constraints
we love aurora we love cinderella but
we're happy that as society moves
forward
so do disney princesses and we're ready
for the next generation of badass women
who can help teach little girls and boys
that being feminine isn't bad
being masculine isn't bad either and
that we all have the right to be exactly
who we are in this
crazy complicated amazing world
so what do you think about how disney
princesses have evolved
what changes would you like to see
disney make next let us know your
thoughts in the comment section down
below
plus don't forget to hit that like
button if you enjoyed this video
and subscribe to our channel for more
thanks for watching and see you next
time